Taylor is with us in Atlanta
hi Taylor how are you hi Dave thanks for
taking my call sure what's up so I'm a
couple months into paying off my student
loans and they've got them separated
into different accounts and each account
has disbursements with different
interest rates so I've started with the
lowest amount of disbursements to kind
of snowball everything and disbursements
what do you mean principal balance so
it's what they dispersed to you right
right so that's what you owe yeah your
own balance should be listed smallest
loan balance two largest loan balance
right and they give me the option to
make a payment on each disbursement
whatever is over and above the minimum
payment hmm so I'm actually ahead on my
payment now you shouldn't do you don't
do that that's pre paying the interest
you need to get you need to get them to
understand what you want to pay the
principal down so it want a prepay
interest I don't be current through
November because you're not getting any
savings by paying it off early by doing
that so it actually does apply to the
principal okay that's not paying ahead
if you put a has a print label down it
does not pay the payment ahead that
that's just the way they have it set up
so the principal is going down but it's
and they say the account is paid ahead
basically what happens now is whatever I
pay each month they're still taking what
they call the regular monthly payment
and spreading it around on interest on
disbursements that I'm not focusing on
so they're basically throwing my money
away on interest that's accruing every
month when I want to apply it to the
principal that's what I'm serving it
that's exactly what I'm saying and you
got it you've got it you've got to
rework that with them and yell at them
until cuz they're not smart people as
you've discovered trying to discuss it
with them because here's the deal okay
if you owe $10,000 and you pay an extra
thousand dollars in principal and it's
the new Oh $9,000 but if you pay
in prepaid payments it does not reduce
your principal or if you pay a thousand
dollars on prepaid payments it does not
reduce your principal by $1,000 you're
paying the other interest that you don't
want to pay and so you know you've got
to pay your minimum payments which
should be covering your interest on all
of your different loan balances which
were originally called disbursements
they're not disbursements now they're
loan balances now and then once you pay
those minimum payments on those then you
start paying extra when you pay the ten
thousand dollar loan down to nine
thousand by paying an extra one thousand
dollars the next month the interest is
not calculated on ten thousand dollars
it's calculated on nine thousand dollars
these are simple interest calculations
assuming you can get the idiot's
and the student loan people to
understand this and oftentimes they
can't and you really really really have
to work on them because you do not want
to pay taxes on ten our pay interest on
ten thousand dollars next month after
you just gave them a thousand dollars
and in principle reduction and because
they screwed up and applied the thousand
dollars for the next five months of
payments and say you're paying ahead
that's the problem with paying ahead
you're paying interest I didn't even do
yet and so it's an improper mathematical
calculation it's not correct it flunks
the sixth grade is what it does and so
you've got to really work it through
with them and try to get them to
understand these needs to be applied to
principal only I do not want to prepay
payments I'm not going to prepay
payments principal only because if you
reached over and just paid the loan off
today they quit charging interest on it
that's principal only see that's exactly
how it works and so a principal only
reduction should have the same effect
that paying off today and fooled us so
you're better off than I even give them
the money than to do what you're talking
about doing just pile it up in a savings
account and reach over and pay it off
and won it because at least then the
interest stops and it doesn't make sense
otherwise but you're right they're very
difficult to deal with hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]